hello everybody my name is Rachel crawl
and thank you for having me here at
strange little conference thanks to the
folks that invited me and free all the
coming out AV folks in the back getting
me miked up and everything this is some
things may never get fixed and if you
saw this title and you've selected this
on your schedule and you're wondering
what the heck is this about well I was
wondering about that too
we had to pick these titles out a while
back so I picked this out kind of
open-ended to be able to figure out what
I was going to do afterward and you know
as time got went on I figured out that
this thing would probably be more about
moving on from another stint in big tech
and if you're not familiar with me I'm
one of these people that lives in
Silicon Valley and you know part of the
problem out there basically yes this has
been a professional cynic according to
somebody in one of my performance
reviews back a long time ago hi Greg and
yeah today we're talking warning tales
about big companies and also some small
ones that may happen to get it wrong
really wrong there will be a couple of
war stories because it wouldn't be a
talk from me without horror stories and
just a warning that good places change
and today's sure thing might be
tomorrow's disaster so okay this comes
up all the time any time I tell a story
people ask me like hey didn't you work
at such-and-such or isn't this story
about this place you must have worked at
this place he must have worked at
Microsoft he much of worsted Verizon
something like that people ask me this
all the time because it sounds like I'm
describing something that's exactly what
happened at their company and you know
what most of the time I did not actually
work there it's funny that the same
thing still happened so you know if you
know me and these stories sound familiar
maybe the answer is yes maybe the story
is about that but also the answer is no
because chances are there's probably 10
different stories from that same company
that might apply you know like how many
times did somebody set all the grid
passwords do the same thing right you
know so ok let's talk a little positive
here we're talking about broken things
but in all likelihood nobody is hired to
break stuff too just outright come in
and make life miserable now I'm not
talking about red team's and tiger teams
these if you're not familiar these are
the folks that in the case of like a red
team they come in and try to break
security on I company systems they try
to win a worm or weasel their way and to
figure out like who can we can we figure
out how to you know compromise somebody
by you know making them view as somebody
else and then we have to log out fifty
million people don't look at tech
reviews these people are actually trying
to make things better I'm not talking
about them red teams are good red teams
are your friend
so are Tiger teams they try to like
break into things know know what I'm
talking about is nobody gets hired to
purposely make this a crappy place to
work hopefully keep that in mind us as
you follow along with me here because
again I mean it nobody is hired to break
stuff
really unless you're working with
Psychopaths that [ __ ] never happen and
you know just to sort of repeat things I
mean nobody is hired to break stuff okay
maybe this guy anybody remember this
yeah airplane all right cool
yeah no there's nobody's hired to break
stuff somebody might be hired to be the
fixer there might be multiple somebodies
for example these are the kind of people
who are given wide access to all kinds
of things inside your company and they
can snoop around they can get into the
source code they could run you know our
PCs and queries and kind of poke at
things and just kind of try and shake it
up and say hey what happens if we do
this Oh what happens if we do this it's
like oh that could be bad somebody could
trip on that right but imagine the
electronic version of that that can
happen now when this is done correctly
they they find things and they get them
fixed and everybody you know learns and
benefits hopefully you have a culture
that shares this kind of knowledge but
unfortunately as I've kind of seen there
can be a dark side to this as well yeah
there are things which are conclusively
broken in this world and when I say
broken conclusively broken I mean like I
could describe it
and anybody in this room computer person
or not would probably look at it and go
yeah I think that's also broken you know
that you wouldn't have you wouldn't have
any ambiguity as to whether like you
know like this thing should be working
should all the Michigan's have the same
password should the clocks be at the
same time you know dumb things like that
right so you would come up with one of
these things to say if you're the fixer
and you report it and you say hey look
this thing is wrong
nobody would challenge that they would
agree yeah that thing is wrong and yet
nothing happens ours might go by days
might go by weeks months even
you could try escalate it you could try
like you know finding a full-bird of you
know a VP full-bird colonel right and
basically ask them like well dude what's
up with this what why are we doing this
nothing
you know you post a little internal
one-on-one group that's just you and the
full bird and the view count goes up to
one or actually two because it's you and
them that's reddit no like no comment I
don't know it still remains broken it's
almost as if somebody wanted it to stay
that way right but that doesn't make
sense nobody would do that on purpose
also we talk about things that broke
hopefully we are in fact talking about
the things that broke like what happened
maybe how it happened in terms of
technological stuff and not throwing
people under the bus if your company has
a culture of having like an annual
review or not annual review sorry a
weekly review where you sit down and you
talk about like what broken the last
week what can we learn from it what can
we do differently then you might call
this a 7 review process you might call
this incident management review it might
call this a post-mortem hopefully you
leave out the who did something because
yeah while it may have been that you
know that intern on their last day of
work that pushed that particular you
know flag flip that turned on the
feature that ended up you know causing
the stock to go down at $20 or whatever
like those things you don't really want
to get into in a public forum because
it's not appropriate it doesn't actually
gain anything and
and only just hurts that person so you
try to stay away from that so you know
companies operate this way and those
companies tend to be healthy but I worry
about one thing when you have this kind
of culture I think this I wonder does
this provide a bunch of convenient
shadows where people could just kind of
hide right can they just kind of cower
behind it and just be like no you can't
see me I'm just doing bad things back
here you know can they get away with
shirking their duties for a very long
time and then when they do what happens
what does that do to reliability so of
course yeah I have stories of being a
fixer who was welcomed with open arms it
was like oh hey come here and work for
us and we'll fix things and everybody
will learn from it things will get
better people will learn from each other
and nobody will purposely slack off you
know deliberately make things worse or
you know avoid fixing things and so you
know for each of our fellow employees
you grow and you learn however of course
is always a dark side here there's the
bad times I also have stories of when
the same behavior tried to fix things
doing the same thing you've been doing
all along for years yielded nothing but
the organizational equivalent of an
immune system response right this is
when like everything gets inflamed and
no matter what you do it just makes it
worse right you know if you've ever
gotten too many bug bites and you've
just all over the place you know at a
certain point there's nothing you can do
because it will just make you break out
more companies work the same way it's
kind of amazing they circle the wagons
they defend their pointless state of
affairs for whatever reason and
sometimes this is just no big deal this
is just one person who's just like you
know this is what we're doing and you
don't go away other times however it can
turn into something truly toxic that has
to be seen to be believed
and then this is where you get into the
realm of you're an unappreciated fixer
you're a troublemaker this is where
people start saying horrible things
about you and they use the anonymous
feedback mechanism of the biannual
performance review of your company to
snipe at you okay so why am i bringing
everybody down with this stuff this is
supposed to be you know happy friendly
and we're supposed to laugh a little bit
here right the guy from airplane was
that hopefully you know to bring
everybody's spirits up well what can you
do well if you're stuck in one of those
visa situations that we do in this
country to people and you have to have
the job just lay low and don't hurt
anybody and just just just I understand
we do awful things to people because
it's basically organized slavery it's
legally legalized slavery on the part of
the federal government I get that if you
have a house if you have a mortgage if
you have kids here if you have a reason
and you cannot leave your job please
don't rock the boat you know just
because you're one of the Rebel Alliance
and you're like I read Rachel by the bay
and she says I should rise up it's like
no no no no no no don't do that right
but if you happen to be privileged and
you you know can legally work here or
Surrey or you know permanent resident or
whatever or you just your parents happen
to hook up on these shores years ago
assuming you're here in the US and you
can just walk out the door and into
another job maybe that's what you should
do but now before you do that you can
turn around and take that feedback that
nasty horrible toxic feedback that you
got and share it with everyone else as
noisily as possible so they can see what
can happen to someone else who is in the
same company who only meant well and yet
you know now they're on the outside now
how does this happen inside a company I
talk about repeat offenders a little bit
here I have this hypothesis it's not
even a theory it's just a just an idea
where I think that they're bees and
vultures that kind of swoop around kind
of circle around and they're looking for
companies when they get to really tasty
places and they're like whoo Wow
look down there look at all the
interesting you know look they're worth
50 billion dollars now right and they've
got so many people they're way past
Dunbar's number this is the 150 or so
people you can keep in your head right
there's no way they'd notice me showing
up so they swoop in and they start
feasting on the remains right or maybe
they you know they start feasting on the
living because that can happen too and
at some point they join a company not
because they want to make it as
successful because they think it's got
you know it can go places but because it
already is successful and they wouldn't
you know they want to get in on the
action watch out for these people right
be wary the vultures they bring about
change when this
when they land and they also spread the
word because I guess voltar's have a
good social network and they they say
that hey things are particularly
succulent over here and the next thing
you know all the opportunists have swept
in and they're gonna consume everything
they find but of course you know there's
there's a way out the only good part
about this whole thing is that people do
move on people pick up and leave they
quit they find better places to be and
they occasionally write cathartic
volumes and share meals with their
fellow survivors and you know get up and
tell stories about it
the people who mattered tend to stick
together because they know that they
will find each other again at the next
place because there's always a next
place but ok this has been depressing
enough depressing stuff I promised you
war stories right so the way this works
here is I'm gonna tell you about some
things that broke that may never have
gotten fixed and made still not be fixed
I'm also I have a couple of war stories
that are built in here we'll go through
them and I also have this slider thing
this crazy thing open on my phone so if
you don't want to put questions in there
I will be looking at them
if we have time at the end if we if we
don't have too many questions I have a
couple of extra bonus war stories that
we can get to and we'll just see how it
works with the time we have
so first up stuff that broke remember
the theme here is if I describe this
anybody reasonable would agree this is
broken and probably needs to be fixed so
this story is called corporate
timekeeping imagine you have lots and
lots and lots of computers there all
over the place and you need to keep them
in sync in terms of time tick tick tick
tick and they all have to hit the same
second at the same time they can't get
faster they can't get slower they have
to just bop bop bop bop bop this is a
hard problem and not just from a physics
perspective right this is a problem of
you know management of computers and
little fiddly bits imagine hundreds of
thousands of machines that you have to
solve this four or more so if you've
worked at a place that has timekeeping
this is old hat to you but I assume
nothing here so I'll give you a brief
primer on how this stuff works usually
so you know we have this this thing that
the government runs the US government
runs
it's called GPS or Navstar and depending
on what you like to think of it it is a
satellite constellation it broadcasts
the signals for you know location so
this is when you're walking around here
and say Lois you know where you are but
as a result of having precise location
information you also have really good
time information so companies benefit
from this they will buy these boxes
these 19-inch rack mountable boxes put
them in a data center and put an antenna
up on the roof and sneak that sucker
down and plug it in there and the Box
this little appliance is $15,000
appliance takes the GPS time and turns
it into NTP Network Time Protocol time
which is not the same thing they're like
17 18 seconds off by this point and I if
you have if you happen to know why
that's the difference that you've run
into the problem of that I'm sorry
that's really painful
anyway this box takes what's coming from
you know one 1500 megahertz basically
and turns it into you know what could be
sent over an Ethernet bling bling bling
bling like that then you've got these
other boxes underneath it than one's
label to in the diagram that are
probably run by like a course systems
team or like an operating system team or
like a like you know they they hit they
they have all kinds of fancy names grid
tetris all these different things
depending on how the parts fit together
these are real names from real companies
and they talk to the appliance box and
they pull time down but you notice
there's also these arrows going like
this between them that's because they
also talk to each other as peers so
notice the twos that's because it's
stratum two this is more time that talk
which basically means it's pulling time
from something that's a stratum one
stratum one of course is the time server
appliance box so that you know they talk
to the appliance to do some peering they
can figure out what time is and then
they share it down word to the clients
and in this case I've only shown three
of them but there could be thousands
their label three because their stratum
three because they're pulling from
stratum two there could in fact be
multiple strata after this with each
with you know tens or hundreds of
thousands of machines but keep in mind
as crazy as this diagram is this you
know with all these interconnecting
and everything this is just one region
and so okay what's a region well think
about your typical startup situation you
have a company and it decides it needs
some servers and so it says hmm
well let's put them in let's say if
they're in Palawan let's put them in
Fremont because it's right on the other
side of the base it's close by it we can
go you know open the cage and fix things
if something breaks so they end up with
a data center on the west coast yay
and then they decide okay well this is
bad because California will fall into
the ocean or something like this will
happen and we need some redundancy also
half and we're clients are on the other
side of the United States and you know
light is slow the traffic to the planet
is big we want to be physically closer
to them so that there's less latency so
they get better results so okay they
start up another region except they
probably call it coasts if you work in a
company that grows through this place
they have a West Coast and an East Coast
they call it this coast in that coast
okay well eventually somebody remembers
that Europe exists and so they end up
with a data center over in Ireland or
the Netherlands or you know some some
other place like that Sweden for example
someplace where you can get you know the
right kind of power the right kind of
you know air conditioning or just cold
air from the outside pump it through at
that point coast no longer makes sense
and so they start calling them regions
so you might have west you might have
East and you might have Europe and of
course Europe will eventually bite you
because they'll be more than one and
then love Asia and they'll be all these
other ones but once you've done that
this diagram which was already pretty
crazy gets even worse because remember
these appliances these network compliant
these time server boxes there will be
multiple of them one per each region and
all of these in between there's level
two stratum 2 boxes end up talking to
the other appliances in other regions
why it because the local appliance might
die now when this happens you're going
across the internet sometimes through a
tunnel you're going across maybe a
private backbone you're saying hi to the
NSA taps as you go through the work the
wires are the fibers you're going under
the ocean dodging the sharks and you're
coming up with some other Shore there's
a lot that can happen to your
pack it in between so a time server
that's really far away is not a good
thing generally but once you've done
this this this this little diagram which
is bad enough as it was looks like this
yeah and and and this imagine this is a
curvature of the earth right and you'll
have this is just throwing three regions
and a big company you might have seven
you might have eight you might get to
the point where you have to start you
know having another level of you know
talk about categorizing things from the
last talk well categorize these right
some of them are gonna be you know west
some we're gonna be east some of them
gonna be America some to Canada some of
this some of that this this is crazy but
this is real this happens all over the
place so remember I said some things may
never get fixed you're ordering okay
Rachel what breaks I'll show you what
breaks one find a one of these little
fifteen thousand dollar 19-inch one you
boxes decides to go on vacation and it's
gone it's dead
maybe it's power supply blows up it's
usually just a little Linux box maybe it
just gets sad maybe it gets routed who
knows but it's gone it is not working
anymore and nobody fixes it that's the
really crazy thing and I don't mean
nobody fixes it on a scale of like you
know a couple of minutes a couple of
hours I'm talking days weeks months go
by what happens is all those stratum two
boxes in that region and I have to reach
out of region to go somewhere else if we
say that's the west coast the one that
just kind of just checked out up there
yeah then it's now going to the east
coast of the US okay so what if I told
you that then because this team was so
proactive and dealing with their time
servers that they also didn't notice
when another one went away yeah and so
now you're down to one time server one
time one appliance that's taking the
satellite data and turning it into NTP
and we'll say that the one on the far
right is Europe so now you have Europe
and the west coast of the US all coming
into the east coast of the US will say
Virginia or something like that
pulling time they're still staying
synchronized kind of sorta that the
margin of error has gotten bigger the
uncertainty has gotten bigger but
now you're worried right now you're like
oh my gosh this is a problem and you're
a fixer and you want to fix this and
things should be getting better but well
what do you do the problem is I things
had conspired already before this point
to where you did not feel comfortable
touching this in public and I'll tell
you why in a second here
so you're thinking in your head okay
cool so these people who did not own the
problem and have not fixed the problem
and the full bird didn't care maybe this
will finally get them exposed right
people will finally go hey look this
team isn't monitoring their stuff and
when they're being told outright that
something broke they're not doing
anything about it either but then oh
okay on the one hand that's awesome
because payback right yeah but on the
other hand oh the site's got to go down
and the jobs are gonna stop running the
servers are gonna get a freak out
because they're not they're not
synchronized and things will stop
working and will someone please think of
the cat pictures because the cat
pictures will just not work anymore we
stop serving cat pictures the metrics
are going down oh my gosh and so at that
point if you're one of these fixers that
wanders around looking for things
this becomes your problem even though
you've been told don't touch this you
know is they would come back to you and
say hey how did you let this happen oh
you knew it was it was there all along
what do you do what do you do if this is
you and I really feel for you if it is
you know come see me afterwards and we
can we can swap story even more stories
but what do you do these boxes again
cost is eight to fifteen thousand
dollars sometimes and you know they're
not just the kind of thing you can just
pop down to Fry's or like Best Buy or
something and pick up but then one fine
day while this is going on you notice
that Amazon happened to be selling
something for 300 bucks that is the size
of a pack of playing cards maybe two and
they can overnight it directly to your
office
clickity clickity clickity click
personal credit card done the result
that
yeah my friend Krusty the Klown here
from from the Simpsons is not there to
bag on the TM 1000 a that's the $300 box
because it is actually quite a nice
little box for the money he's also not
there to bag on the ntp clock underneath
it that's the the thing with the 336 on
it since that is also a halfway decent
device from the price as long as a you
only speak ipv4 never want to speak a
few v6 and B never ports can your clocks
with n map but that's another story
just trust me that oh let me just put it
this way connect to it 10 times to port
80 all at once with net cat in the
background and it will reboot yeah okay
that's a fun bug report no Krusty is
there because this is the plan which
will save the world you take this box
and you take the little GPS puck and you
put it put it up in your window because
there's a window right there you can see
it and it happens to have enough of a
view to get a lock and that's what
that's a yellow LED that is there in the
middle it says luck obviously when they
took the picture you couldn't see it but
the third one for all the time that's
out there that's the PPS signal it
actually blinks at the rising edge is
pretty sweet and that and the clock
underneath it we're going boop boop boop
at the same time this is the planet
which will save the world should that
last time server die you're going to
back feed time from your desk in the
secret and you're going to plug it into
the production network
these are jumper cables for the
corporate clocks basically so okay
you're probably wondering like how in
the heck does this happen how much money
does this company make right what is the
$15,000 box it's nothing so why didn't
the fixers just go buy another real
clock and put it in somewhere why didn't
they just ship one to the data center
that had the problem when it broke why
didn't they ship one to the other data
center when it broke why was this backup
clock ordered in secret and just
mysteriously showed up with somebody's
desk with no information and it was just
treated it's like oh yeah that person's
own nerd and they like having it there
why was it bought with personal money
why was it there just in case this is
because there was a meeting earlier that
year it was called hands off our clocks
and this was after something called leap
smear now if your time nuts you probably
have already heard of this but that
particular year we had ADA leap second
this is where the rotation of the earth
slows down to the point where we need to
add an extra second to either the last
minute or the last minute of June or of
December in this case it was June
because you can see 181 here right day
number 181 and when this happens the UTC
the you know the Universal Time
basically has a time which is 23 59 60 I
was on the west coast of the US and so
this is this is you know four o'clock in
the afternoon turning into five where we
were now
previous times this had happened the
extra second had broken things really
badly for the company and so the the
fixers rigged up this smear and this is
where you take the time you take the
extra second and you spread it out
across the entire day you make every
second of the day for about 20 hours
slightly longer so that over 20 hours
you eventually pick up the extra second
now the whole company slowed down rather
than have to deal with what happens
because like on a UNIX box
honestly the time you don't get that
extra second it goes it restarts it and
does it again it's pretty pretty freaky
this is using Google's original
technique by the way not their current
one before they published the algorithm
you know had to figure out you have to
figure out how to turn the how the
rhythm in the working code this code is
now in ntpd by the way for those of you
who know these things but at the time it
wasn't so what you see here the top
clock is UTC although it's showing
showing it in the Pacific Standard time
that we were Pacific what is it anymore
in the in the summertime's Pacific
Daylight Time isn't it and then the
bottom one was company name here time
and this is what it looked like when the
rest of the world had its extra second
and we didn't and one second later the
smear itself worked both clocks went to
that and so it worked perfectly but you
know so you figure okay this is this has
been a triumph this is the great thing
everything's fine it's a folks who
nominally owned time at this company
gotten mad and a little sad both and
they said stop touching things these are
our clocks why did you touch them well
they had been told about the smear or
the attempt to smear based on the leap
second months in advance this really
cool group called the International
earth rotation service greatest name
ever announces these things usually in
the first week of January the first week
of July for what's gonna happen to six
months hence and so you know in January
of whatever year this was there was
there was this post that was like okay
we're gonna have to do this they had
been told about it they did nothing
and again the fixers had this LD I let
him crash her DL n ik you know do you
fix the thing well in this case it the
answer was fixed the thing and just get
in there and smear time out and just do
it the hard way the tech was fine it was
all politics these politics held the
whole place back yeah if this is you
what do you do
chances are you're not alone in this you
can make friends you can talk to other
people and I don't just mean clicking
that little button that says you're now
friends with this person I mean you
could actually make friends and you can
find other folks to talk to right even
here I'm sure there's other folks based
on some of the laughter that have gone
through this and I like and that wasn't
just me it's like no you're not alone
we're together in this
ask them about what's going on in there
alright sit down and listen don't even
talk just listen see what's happening
and once you've heard what's going on
with them and swap some stories tell
them what's going on with you
and you can bond over these things sysem
mints tend to bond over really nasty
things that are like the worst gallows
humor you can imagine and by that I
don't mean like anything that's like not
safe for work and I don't mean things
that that like marginalize people I mean
just talking about tech and just then
just the nasty gunky things we have to
do to keep it working and then of course
yes you get snarky because because you
know this stuff you have to or otherwise
you'd kind of go nuts because it defies
logic sometimes it's like how can this
actually be and so finally getting a
little meta here you take questions you
give a talk and you take questions so at
this point we have about 12 minutes here
and I've got some questions sitting here
and I also have a couple of hidden war
stories so let me take a look and let's
see what people want to know so what is
your opinion on tools like glass door
how can employees best give accurate and
anonymous feedback without being unfair
or being punished internal processes
glass door to me is I believe how people
publish what salaries write and they
basically say like this is what it's
like on the inside
um I always worry about those things
because there are companies who will try
to astroturf these things and they will
say hey you please go out and vote us up
please do this please do that and of
course then you'll get other people who
have had nothing but a bad time that
will post things and so you get
selection bias going the other way and I
don't know that you can ever really get
a good read on things this way
but how could employees give accurate
anonymous feedback without being
punished yeah that's a I wish I knew a
good answer for that internal processes
the question here basically is like if
you have like a performance review
system it might be called PSC it might
be called perf it might be called any of
a number of things but how do you do
that I don't know if you're sufficiently
paranoid you'll think somebody will look
at the writing style and know oh this
person uses uses the word y'all
and so hey this might be that person so
there's never really truly anonymous I
would think that if you wanted to try to
do something like that you could try and
do something really horrible and
passive-aggressive and route it through
somebody else and be like hey can you
tell that person that maybe they should
look at their clock and I hope that
answered your question but if it didn't
you know feel free to like post an
update here different questions how do
you distinguish vultures from people who
actually see a problem what to introduce
changes so that's a good question so to
me in my hypothesis the vulture is
somebody who is like oh hey look there's
darling company X and they they have
their just flush with money they have
all kinds of opportunities they're
hiring like crazy they're creating
traffic jams because there's so many
people working there now and I would
just want to get in there and just suck
that place dry I want to get all the
resources out of it I would distinguish
those from the people who are like oh
that place looks promising that place
could go places someday I want to get in
there and make it happen
and whether this is pre IPO post IPO or
whatever the equivalent is for where
you're coming from that well that's
another story but people who see a
problem with to introduce changes that's
interesting so is this would this be the
kind of thing where like you say hey
this company doesn't understand social
this company is a bunch of systems
people trying to build social rather
than bunch of social people trying to
build systems and you know one will work
and one won't and I'm a social person so
I want to get in there and help I
wouldn't call that a vulture I would
call that somebody who actually wants to
help it grow right because if you see
some company that's just chronically bad
at whether it's customer service or
social skills or technical skills or any
of these other things and you have a
unique take on it you want to help I
don't think you're a vulture I I think
you're somebody who's like you know from
each according to what they can provide
and you can provide that so you know
that seems that seems legit to me you've
got my thumbs up on that oh this is
interesting so new question thank you
for this one stepping into fix things
for people who are refusing to do their
job reminds me of the description of
codependency yeah zing okay yeah why not
let things fail so they learn oh my god
right here
okay I mean you you wonder why you walk
out of jobs like this is because you
start reading things and you realize man
this could be me I could be doing this
stuff I could be enabling these things
and the the problem is is like you have
this this like I said it's this duality
it's this balance you have to do where
it's like on the one hand yeah let them
feel let them hit the brick wall maybe
it'll get fired
the thing yes I usually don't they
usually don't right I realized I
shouldn't really whisper because then
they can't really transcribe it right no
they usually don't
and but the like these people go on
longer than you can imagine at these
companies and I wonder like what do you
have on the senior management of this
company that they haven't fired you yet
right do you have some kind of like
not-safe-for-work tape of them doing
nasty things in the back alley or
something like that it's like what is up
with this remember we got to keep it PG
rated here right so you know just use
your imaginations like why are these
people still here how are they getting
away with this and why are other people
just beating themselves up for this for
this job that's more than a job for them
it's like their whole life they live and
breathe it if you cut them they bleed
that particular Pantone color blue did I
say blue whatever and oh whoops there it
is why not why not let's think fail so
they learn well hopefully you don't have
to let them fail for them to learn I
mean I personally I like to try and
teach people things right just kind of
sidle up to them and just open up a chat
message or literally walk over to them
if they're not like on the other side of
the world it'd be like hey did you know
you can monitor this stuff this way in
fact that's one of the war stories I
have cued up here if we want to if we
have time to get to it is there is a way
to monitor those boxes that blow up so
that they don't have to be like oh that
looks weird now they can actually get an
alert and it would be like hey you know
you're not serving time anymore
and you can go to them on the DL you can
just talk to them you don't get the
manager involved you don't get anybody
else involved they listen to you they
learn from it they grow they do things
but what if they don't do it then what
if they just be like look talk to the
hand
I'm busy I don't care or or I'm doing
other things that's like really what are
you doing that's more important than all
the clocks I don't know it's it's it's
not a good thing that's not a good
situation
okay let's see what or what I described
the most painful soul-crushing work
environment relating to politics not
tech but I've ever suffered through and
how I dealt with it what I described it
yeah it's it's in a mudflat in Menlo
Park it's right off highway 84 in Menlo
Park California that's probably the most
painful work environment is that what
you mean by describe it's it's it's got
these big open spaces you have desks
that kind of run on forever you don't
have any offices they've got these
things called micro kitchens you have
these you have these little badges and
stuff and beep-beep no but in terms of
politics
seriously though in terms of politics
like what kind of stuff am I talking
about okay let me tell you some of the
feedback I got this was back in January
so I used to give a class about what to
do when something broke and I would talk
to all the new people that came into the
company and so like 200 people every two
weeks give or take it was you know much
smaller than this and we'd pack them in
and I would get up here and do this well
I'll get up there and do a
song-and-dance talking about like what
do you do
openness of there's no shame in opening
a set of do this do that and I
cultivated this this kind of persona of
being the person who tells you about how
things have broken how we don't fire you
because things are broken because then
we'd have to fire everybody because
everybody's broken something including
me that was the culture that's the way
things worked
but after reporting some of these things
unfortunately things shifted and things
turned around to where now the now the
story was not positive the story was
negative and at one point I was actually
told do not open a security-related sev
a site event is severity depending on
where you've come from without talking
to this full-bird or this manager and
I'm the person who's teaching people
about subs and that there's no shame in
opening one and apparently when pressed
the antthony answer was you've been
disrupting the prioritization of the
security teams
really
okay I thought I was opening them
because they were doing the work and I
was helping them out you know when you
have people actually solving a problem
and you're just there reporting it you
go oh I will go into the tool and go
clickety clickety click for you so that
you don't have to see no swap out and
drop all that state in your head but
when I was told that it was like whoo
things have gotten chilly in here things
are not good the culture has shifted and
you know it takes a lot out of you
because it's like Here I am the seventh
person and yet I can't open a set-off
without getting permission first
and yet we tell every employee that they
should be able to just go and do this if
they think something's wrong and it's
that bad it's like I could never teach
my class again after I was told that
that's an example of Silla crushing
there's a couple others but I won't
subject to them here its subject you to
them here because there's probably other
questions
isn't this a problem where management
simply won't take the actions for the
best good of the company
um what is the best good of the company
right they're still in business they're
gonna make a lot of money off those cat
pictures the fact that I'm gone changes
me nothing all right the thing that
happened today and nothing to do with me
being there and not being there logging
out 50 million people all that kind of
stuff they'll be just fine
they will be just fine they do not need
me so honestly I don't know I think I
think they could keep going I think that
that there's a long there's a short road
from awesome place to work to not
awesome place to work but there's a long
road from not awesome place to work to
dead and like you can ride this out if
you want but I wouldn't recommend it
once it goes from here to here Bale
right if you can again if you have
reasons for staying here if you're on
some godforsaken visa and you are you
are shackled in that company until they
finally sponsor you I'm sorry I feel for
you as a citizen here I am really sorry
that we've done this to you we should be
treating our friends better than that it
makes me it makes me want to cry because
it's like I have good friends who are
literally 10 days away from being kicked
out of the company or the country the
country if the company says get gone
baby get lost all because they didn't
make it to level five within five years
it's terrible it's terrible we do this
to human beings every day
and finally one person is asking let's
hear some of those other stories we have
two minutes left here so we can rip into
this real quick if you want to see one
of these things um okay so bonus story
open sourcing root access to the entire
fleet hopefully this will give you a
laugh so there these machines they run
Linux and then the machines themselves
have another machine on top because you
know management stuffs you can remote
into it
those machines also run Linux and again
this may have happened anywhere do not
read anything into this now it turned
out that all the machines the management
machines these little bitty things up on
top all had the same root password and
it was really stupid it was easy to
guess it was likely to speak you know
what I mean lead speak is where you take
them like the letter e and turn it into
three you take the letter O and turn it
into zero that kind of stuff yeah or and
that it was really stupid it was easy to
guess it had been checked into code
because there were people like logging
in automatically programmatically
instead of using proper crypto stuff and
keys and the worst part because this was
an open source project you could google
it you could actually orb or ping it you
know you could go out and you can look
for what is the root password for this
kind of management system and it would
be like okay cool here it is right so
you get you get console access to the
machine and people are like who cares
this console access well guess what when
you have console access to a Linux box
and you can reboot it you can interrupt
grub when it comes up and say hey you
instead of starting in it why don't you
start this thing called bin bash why
don't you start a shell for me and the
Machine boot sub mounts the filesystem
read-only and says here's your shell and
then you mount you take the shell and
you say hey that filesystem with Slash
looks good let's make it read right so
once you've done that you say add user
tour and you say password tour hahahaha
and then you remount the thing read-only
to reboot the box and you bail out and
then assuming they allow SSH with
passwords you Association as tour you
type in hahahahahaha your route or you
can backdoor any of a number of ways the
point is if you have console access to a
box and they don't have some kind of
crypto or something locking it down you
can own the box over a year
and nothing happened and finally I I
reported it I was like here's a salve
fire me but this is getting fixed they
didn't fire me but it did poison the
well to where I wanted out and I bailed
and with that
the thing is blinking at me it is sad so
we have reached the end but please come
find me we can talk about all kinds of
other things and thank you for having me
[Applause]